are you two wearing the same
suit oh you know we yeah
tag team this thing right
we're trying to have a yeah we're trying
to have a moment it's a twin moment look
the moment's happening what was behind
the twinning decision
honestly i went in uh
to meet my good friends at isaiah and
and and get this and um
it was kind of amazing it was like a
meeting of the minds yeah all of this
all the men they pulled out
they're like why don't you wear it too
and she's like oh
thanks yeah she looks amazing in it so
now you look like a superhero thank you
yeah it's great what is the red branch
that's there it's ia yeah it's it's
coral isn't it isn't it beautiful
well you know what twinning is winning
um and look you two you're not like
married that long are we still in the
honeymoon phase we're so in love we're
dressing alike oh god obviously we're
still on the honeymoon phase where we're
like wearing matching outfits no this is
our everything i was gonna grow my hair
out actually
well this is our forever face this is my
this is my pigment
sorry
this is my man i can't take her anywhere
sorry is this where you know we were
kept inside the house that's why we
don't go out
you know what let's talk about it we're
out does it feel good to just be getting
a date night out and about in a little
dress
yes it feels good to see your face
you know what i mean let's see how many
f-bombs we can drop in this section
well let's talk about how the show is
effing nominated
okay um isn't that amazing
it's a you know we're a network show and
everybody always qualifies it as network
show but i i you look at
i used to look at it like well that's
kind of a slight why are people saying
network show and then i look at it and i
go it's not a slight it's an
accomplishment
we're doing
we're doing 18 episodes of television
per year no one does that on streamers
so they get the luxury of that and um
and yet here we are after six seasons
you know and the show is nominated and
the individual nominations are great i'm
glad that susan got recognized sterling
of course honored to be nominated myself
but the baby is the show when the show
gets nominated everybody gets nominated
which is wonderful
look i know it's an emotional time for
you guys it's all wrapping up we're
getting the kevin episode right what can
we expect on tuesday yeah i think this
is when you know you've walked through
this guy's life for the past five six
years and you've seen him go up and down
trials and tribulations and you've seen
him sort of struggle with becoming a man
getting stuck in the past addiction
issues commitment issues
insecurity and you you sort of you see
it all come to a head and you which way
is he going to go can he handle it can
he not handle it he's got kids now so a
lot of kevin's story gets told on
tuesday have you guys fully wrapped no
we go until may okay we have a few more
you gonna cry
right now no it's just then uh not
tonight i mean i don't know you know i
don't know i i i'm not a massive crier
but if there was ever a time that i
would be uh
in tears it might be it might be that
yeah maybe you're just bawling at
kevin's plight
you're the only one crying
i can't handle it
could we see you up here on this as us
oh yeah well no
don't give it away i'm kidding
well you guys we need to see you guys
work together again soon i mean look i
know i know i know we definitely want to
let's find you for the right project
yeah oh god yeah it would be fun